(Marial sighs)
- What?
- Your mother is on her way here.
A rider, she's less than an hour away.
- Mother? Huzzah!
(excited orchestral music)
Ooh!
(Catherine breathing heavily)
(Catherine squeals)
- Bubble, bubble.
Bubble, bubble.
Pop!
(Catherine screams)
Oh, my Catherine.
My dear one.
- Oh, sorry, I just-
- Needed your mother and
found an empty space.
Mm.
Come, the space is empty no more.
Now, young lady,
there is a rumor sweeping Europe
that you have taken
Russia from your husband.
- Guard.
- Yes, Empress.
- Who's the leader of Russia?
- Yes are, Empress.
(Catherine laughs)
Huzzah!
- Huzzah!
- What is huzzah?
- Huzzah. It's a lot of things.
All purposes, variously.
Also, you notice, I am pregnant!
- Oh, I had hoped that's what it was.
Russians can be quite fat. (chuckles)
I had feared you'd turned native.
For a mother who set her heart
on marrying her four
daughters to kings of Europe,
(sighs) and no one would
believe it when I said I would,
they thought it madness.
- But you always saw it.
- And then to have done it.
And for the final one to be
France, the jewel of Europe.
And then.
- And then?
- And then you overthrew your husband
and the deal was off.
No one wants to risk a rebellion
from inside the marriage bed.
- I'm-
- Sorry?
Speechless?
Which?
Either would be fabulous.
Both would be appropriate.
- Sorry.
- You are who you are.
Always were.
And I love you for your
crazy mind and willful ways.
But you have cost your sister
greatly with this whim.
- This is not a whim. It is my destiny.
- We were talking of your sister.
- Yes, I'm sorry. Yes.
- I will have to make a new plan.
It will be difficult now.
- I do not wish us to
misunderstand each other.
I love your daughter. I am on her side.
- Oh, I thought you were on Russia's side.
- They are the same. She is Russia.
- She is a child with
a dazzling intelligence
and a dizzying belief
in the power of herself.
And if she is being duped into using these
to put herself in grave danger
at the behest of others,
then those people are no friends of mine.
- I assure you-
- I am sure you do.
(butterfly crunches)
Oh.
Poor Sergei.
He is unwell.
(Joanna exhales sharply)
(gentle music)
I don't find you interminable.
I find you thrilling.
- Ah.
(Peter groans)
- Mother, are you all right?
I'm mortified.
- I thought that was it for a moment.
I thought you'd killed me.
- Don't say that!
I'm sorry.
- I need to rest.
There's a list of
everyone you should kill.
- Mother, they fought for me.
- You don't know what they fought for.
- It's funny, I was just thinking,
sometimes I miss my mother.
- Hmm.
- Her being dead at an early age
and sometimes I'm glad she's dead,
as I have lived my own
life on my own terms.
- Subtle.
- What are you?
- We have some concerns.
Seeing you with your mother,
you are not quite yourself.
- We worry what she does to you.
- You mean beside love me
beyond any human on this earth?
Care for me and my sisters
like we are precious gems?
Make a home for us
and ignite a fire in us to
be the special ones we are?
- She perhaps does not
understand us is our point.
- We worry she wants us dead.
- Oh, she did give me a
list and you were on it.
- Oh. I'm first.
- Oh, relax.
She has always wanted people dead.
For months once, she plotted
the death of our neighbor Hess
as he had eyed Donna in a
way she had found disturbing.
We would gather 'round
with tea and kugelhopf
and we would all have to think of ways
we would kill him and get away with it.
- Fun game. We'd just play chess.
- Ladies, you may all go.
But I thank you for the
insight into your lives.
It has inspired me.
- Why are you getting up?
- I need paper.
- Darling, what are you doing?
- She has that look.
What do you need?
- I will set up in here.
Marial, get me the current
legal codes regarding women and-
- What are you talking about?
- Think of it, a woman with
the right to divorce a man.
- Think of the freedom
that would give women
who suffer violence, drunkenness,
men rutting on them while
sweating and smelling of cheese.
(Elizabeth inhales sharply)
It would change the very
dynamics between men and women.
Also, women as property, that must stop.
- Oh!
- You must stop this.
It is a delirium.
- Is that not exciting?
To change the systems women live by,
take power from men and give it to us.
- It is easy to take power from men,
and sometimes they even enjoy it,
but what you must not do
is advertise about it,
for then their fists come out.
Someone tried to kill you, darling.
- I'm dealing with it.
It's part of the job.
- And you will die if we
don't change the game.
And we can.
- What?
- In three days time,
you will have this baby
and there is a natural pause.
You transition out of
power and into motherhood
and Peter transitions back in,
and it can addressed through
Europe as some strange rumor
and I can get your sister
the French job back.
- What?
- It could all be just as I planned.
And you can be safe.
Darling, you can play that boy.
We both can. Trust me.
You're staring at me blankly.
- I'm just a piece in
your perfect tableau.
The maestro of marriage.
- You were born to be a royal wife.
You were trained to be a royal wife.
Be one and stop this and live.
Darling, your sisters
can do it, why can't you?
- Because I am not them. I'm better.
(hand slaps)
Oh!
Oh.
- Darling.
See, it's crazy statements like that
that make me worry
about your mental state.
- Recognize who and what I am or leave.
- Recognize that you are mad.
And you need help.
And I am here to give it.
- Get out of my palace.
- Catherine.
- Get out of my country.
(dramatic music)
Go!
- Chew, little Cat.
Chew, chew, chew.
But I will not stick
around while you choke.
(dramatic music)